[Música]
[Aplausos]
que el monstro grupo para compartir una
terrible experiencia que tuve
en mi barrio en mi cuadra y en la
cotidianeidad porque nuestra vida
nuestra existencia pasa por el día por
el momento nadie vive un año dos años en
un día se vive por día y por momentos
bueno estaba saliendo de mi casa estaba
muy contento había sol y de repente piso
algo resbaladizo gelatinoso con mucho
olor nauseabundo hediondo estaba pisando
caca de perro concretamente y
y ahí ya me vino el día me puse muy
chinchudo y dije bueno me voy al parque
a limpiar esa indignación a limpiarme la
[ __ ] del perro y aparte para
distraerme en el césped del parque pero
qué pasó cuando llego
resulta que el parque estaba este estaba
totalmente privatizado por en la basura
de cartones botellas de vidrio botellas
de plástico bolsas de plásticos dije no
me tengo que ir de acá entonces me voy
pero antes voy a tomar agua porque hacía
mucho calor voy a estar el viejo
bebedero y tampoco funciona el bebedero
todo terrible bueno dije me voy de acá
me voy de acá me voy de este lugar no
voy a tomar el colectivo que quedaba
pocas cuadras bajo un sol que me rompía
la cabeza con mucho olor por la [ __ ]
que tenía en los pantalones
y transpirado realmente era un día muy
pesado voy a tomar el colectivo esperó
10 esperó 15 esperó 30 minutos qué pasó
con la aplicación no lo sé porque la
aplicación decía 7 minutos y espere 30
minutos lleno de gente
abajo esperando lleno de gente con el
colectivo cuando llegó
es decir entramos como ganado y un
chofer que decía continuamente atrás
atrás
busquemos lugar no había lugar para nada
ni para nadie en ese colectivo bueno
subimos igual yo sudoroso perdidos o con
mucho calor con sed oloroso sigo en el
colectivo hasta que me bajo me bajo en
un banco porque no tiene un peso con
todo estos problemas que me habían
pasado
llegó al banco que hay en el banco una
cola impresionante una cola
impresionante y después de una hora
aparece un hombre alto y dice se cayó el
sistema se tienen que ir yo no sé si era
el sistema solar sin el sistema
galáctico pero quedaba bien como frase
que dije de este tipo que se acababa la
atención al público porque se había
caído el sistema se te altura el partido
estaba caliente pero muy caliente y no
por amor y realmente estaba casta con
saliva y no era porque hubiera tomado o
espuma vino era porque hubiera tomado
cerveza y me voy de ese banco luego de
una hora de espera a otro banco a otro
banco y en ese otro banco también una
cola impresionante y estoy esperando
hasta que bueno tengo necesidad de
fisiológica también porque soy un ser
humano
y ahí le digo al gerente que pues si me
puede prestar el baño del banco bueno
este gerente me dice no acá solamente se
trabaja con dinero ligó pero qué hago
con mis necesidades a no vos y todos los
que vienen acá tienen que venir con
pañales me voy ya muy enfurecido de este
día terrible a mi casa a mi casa buscar
un refugio a tanta hostilidad ciudadana
tan ante tanta hostilidad de la ciudad
cuando llegó en el colmo de los colmos
me encuentro con la bolsa de basura que
siempre pone el vecino de al lado en un
gran acto de siempre que hace de fatiga
moral de fatiga física que no lo quieren
llevar al contenedor y me lo deja ahí en
la puerta de mi casa quien lo lleva al
contenedor el que el que les habla yo
los llevo hasta allá y evidentemente ese
día fue terrible para mí y me preguntaba
me preguntaba qué pasa la sociedad qué
pasa en nuestras
que hay una suerte de colesterol mental
que nos hace ver que todo acto de
amabilidad es un acto totalmente
irritativo es más tenemos posiciones en
contra de la amabilidad creemos que con
la amabilidad perdemos cuando al
contrario
ganamos en convivencia es decir tenemos
contradicciones que no asumimos que
criticamos lo que hacen los otros cuando
nosotros mismos lo hacemos paramos en
doble fila paramos en doble fila en la
calle cuando lo hacemos nosotros está
bien pero cuando lo hacen los otros está
mal si vamos la mascota
y se hace y se defeca en la vereda y es
nuestra mascota está bien es más hasta
nos ofendemos si el vecino de al lado
nos reclama algo ahora si nos hacen eso
mismo a nosotros está mal porque esa
contradicción porque esa soberbia de no
asumir que tenemos contradicciones que
esas contradicciones tenemos que
mejorarlas disminuirla para lograr
mejores niveles de convivencia
pero no queda ahí y en esas
contradicciones que tenemos es que no
reclamamos derechos por ejemplo no nos
bancamos porque nos da vergüenza porque
nos hacen creer que es berreta o porque
podemos quedar miserable el derecho de
jarras de agua esto significa reclamar
no quejarse reclamar para que te den
agua potable libre y gratuita en los
bares en los restoranes en las
universidades en las escuelas públicas
en las entidades privadas
con atención al público como también
entidades públicas con la atención al
público esto es un derecho y que lo
tenemos que ejercer el derecho al agua
potable libre y gratuita se llama
derecho de jarras y sin embargo entramos
la contradicción de la vergüenza
también tenemos vergüenza de reclamar
por el derecho a los sanitarios libres
estos que es el derecho a los sanitarios
libres es que si yo estoy en la
situación de paciente de la ciudad sí
porque puedo pasear la ciudad de un ser
humano puedo estar paseando en mi ciudad
la ciudad de otros donde si tengo
necesidad de fisiológica que es un
derecho humano el derecho al saneamiento
que pueda ir al baño de la universidad
al baño de la epe al baño de la entidad
municipal de un bar de un restaurant y
que no me cobren absolutamente nada sin
embargo nos quejamos pero no ejercemos
las cosas que hacemos para los
colectivos para exigir que el colectivo
cumpla con la aplicación que sea
correcto no solamente el horario sino
también la cantidad de gente que puede
estar en el colectivo y sin embargo qué
hacemos qué hacemos la de siempre
quejarnos pero no reclamamos la queja la
queja es la comodidad nuestra prisa es
queja que la comodidad a nuestra nos
hace mal porque no mejoramos la sociedad
en cambio el reclamo y la participación
en lo que nos permite convivir y vivir
de otra manera pero más fácil la queja
me quejo un momento después lo soluciono
y me voy ahora bien nombre estos
derechos y cuando estoy en el parque
tengo otro derecho en el parque el verde
que es el derecho a los bebederos
públicos de poder acceder a este derecho
humano que es agua potable libre y
gratuita en el siglo 21
como hacemos para que logremos dejar de
quejarnos comprometernos y reclamar ante
el estado ante las distintas entidades
levantemos la mano quien se compromete
para realizar esas cuestiones y no
quedarse la queja que mira al otro de
costado y si se queje no hace
absolutamente nada y yo la puedo
levantar a la mano porque evidentemente
todos caemos la comodidad y hay que
asumirlo hay que asumir las
contradicciones porque la mejor manera
de superarlo y nosotros los argentinos
tenemos una gran capacidad de
contradicciones y no las asumimos y es
importante que logremos eso porque vamos
a ir en el camino de la mejora no no por
ejemplo no somos capaces de reclamar
que el colectivo funcione bien que no me
hagan esperar y esto es muy importante
también que no me hagan esperar porque
nosotros somos tiempos finitos
todos somos tiempo finito sabemos que
nacemos nos desarrollamos y morimos la
vida la muerte forma parte de la vida
eso lo sabemos todo consciente o
inconscientemente es así de todo
habitante de la tierra es así del punto
de vista la biología y de la
espiritualidad también ahora bien como
puede ser que nosotros no reclamemos por
el derecho al trato respetuoso como
cuando nos hacen hacer colas en bancos
más de una hora en entidades municipales
en el colectivo en el médico en el
dentista y no hacemos nada si nos
quejamos después cuando resolvimos la
cuestión individual nos vamos y si nos
va la vida vamos a hacer un cálculo
ahora entre todos sabemos el celular
tomemos el celular y hagamos esta
aproximación
vamos a suponer que todos invertimos
mejor dicho e invertimos nos perdemos
dos horas de nuestra existencia por día
en el colectivo esperándolo en el
supermercado en el dentista en el médico
que siempre hay que esperarlo siempre
hay que esperarlo en el hospital en la
administración pública cuando tiene que
hacer trámite y la lista puede seguir si
tomamos la aproximación que vamos a
hacer de dos horas por día hacemos dos
vamos a suponer que son dos horas por
días y si hacemos dos por cinco vamos a
suponer le que sábado y domingo no
hacemos cola no hacemos espera estamos
entonces hacemos dos horas por día por
cinco llegamos a diez horas semanales
que perdemos de nuestra existencia en
colas y en espera hasta ahí si yo
multiplico estas diez horas
x
cuatro semanas que tiene el mes llegamos
a 40 horas que perdemos de nuestra
existencia haciendo colas y espera si
multiplicamos esas 40 horas me siguen
está
si seguimos con las 40 horas esto es
dramático pero hay que hay que pensarlo
pensemos que un paréntesis que si
hacemos promedio hasta 80 años son 29
mil días que vivimos nuestra existencia
si lo hacen cálculo de días impactan
bueno si hacemos 40 horas y lo
multiplicamos por 12 nos da cuánto nos
da cuánto nos da ha dicho el cálculo 480
nos da 480 horas anuales
si yo divido 480 dividido 24 horas que
tiene el día me da
20 días esperando 20 días esperando
anualmente 20 días que son de tu
existencia 20 días que poco dedicarle a
tu familia 20 días para viajar 20 días
para preparar una materia 20 días para
estar con tu mamá con tus hermanos 20
días de espera es terrible esto proyecto
existe y en la y en ciudades que son
grandísimas los tiempos muertos que se
llama en el urbanismo los tiempos
muertos superan este cálculo totalmente
es importante que dejemos el pensamiento
rumiante
nosotros tenemos mucha capacidad de
pensamiento rumiante el pensamiento
rumiante es esa capacidad que tenemos
para criticar que me dijo este que me
dijo la otra mira como se viste mira
como se dejó de vestir mira como se fue
el 15 y dónde está
y en eso no me saludó viste que no me
saludó y yo le fui a tratar de saludarla
mira lo que me hizo y peter como vino
vestida o como vino vestido este un
irrespetuoso y perdemos tiempo así
es evidente que tenemos que hacer una
gran transformación cultural y en ese
sentido
en estos derechos que he mencionado el
derecho a la ciudad amable que contiene
estos derechos el derecho de jarras de
agua el derecho a los sanitarios libres
el derecho al trato respetuoso por el
tema de la escola y la espera el derecho
a los bebederos públicos están
contenidos en el derecho a la ciudad
amable el derecho a la ciudad amable es
el derecho a poder convivir
armoniosamente dos de mis derechos
me liberaliza pero me obliga frente al
otro me liberaliza a mí pero me obliga
frente al otro es una obligación frente
al otro y liberaliza esto es muy
importante tenerlo en cuenta y hay una
cuestión
es la conducción nueva del derecho a la
ciudad mable es que el derecho es una
conducción cultural
luego deviene legalidad luego deviene
norma jurídica hay millones de ejemplos
de eso
valga la redundancia por ejemplo acá
el derecho antes de que se llegara a la
normativa que prohibía fumar un consenso
cultural para decir basta de fumar en
colectivo en aviones en lugares cerrados
bueno acá hay mucha juventud pero muchos
de los que están acá se acuerdan que en
el avión en colectivo de larga y urbano
se fumaba y lo mismo pasaba en
sanatorios y hospitales que se fumaba
hasta que un consenso cultural que
empezó a ruptura esto y después devino
en la norma jurídica a la legalidad lo
mismo pasó con el chofer del colectivo
el chofer del colectivo hace 25 años
atrás daba el cambio recibía plata
tendría que expedir el boleto y ordenar
el pasaje y encima nadie nadie le exigía
y el estado le exigía perdón que no
cometiera infracciones en el circuito
urbano cuando esa persona hacía cinco
tareas y podía chocar a cualquiera eso
también hubo un consenso cultural para
que se dejara de lado esa multiplicidad
que hacían los choferes de colectivo el
tema
del maltrato de las mujeres los piropos
que hostigaban y actualmente y antes y
actualmente ahora que se vea como algo
naturalizado ahora en consenso cultural
del acoso de los piropos hacia las
mujeres esto significa una vez más lo
que decía antes que el derecho es una
construcción cultural que después de
viene después deviene legalidad y hay
muchísimos ejemplos más que le puedo
decir por ejemplo que la edad media la
niñez no existía luego fue una
construcción cultural que se
establecieron los derechos del niño el
gran media se consideraba al niño como
un hombre adulto en un cuerpo chiquito
hay muchísima bibliografía en este
sentido no estoy diciendo nada nuevo
pero es para ratificar que el derecho es
cultura y luego deviene en norma ahora
bien este derecho a la ciudad amable
implica varias cosas también primero
necesitamos una sociedad con autoestima
todos tienen que tener mucha autoestima
una sociedad sin autoestima es imposible
que ayuda al prójimo al semejante al
otro yo sí me quiero voy a querer al
otro yo si no me quiero si mi vida para
mí no vale la de loto tampoco va a valer
es imposible en principio eso segundo es
importante que el otro no es mi
competidor el otro o la otra es el que
se integra conmigo en la comunidad no es
mi competencia porque si mi competencia
del otro alguien tiene que ganar alguien
tiene que perder la competencia es así
en cambio el grado de superación mía va
a estar dado no en la competencia sino
en la autosuperación
y me junto con el otro con la otra en
grado de integración con la comunidad
entonces lo que necesitamos superación
no competencia porque insisto sea
competencia alguien gana alguien tiene
que perder eso genera resentimientos o
genera malestar la otra cuestión que
requiere el derecho a la ciudad amable
que fundamental que entre lo que decimos
y los que hablamos que haya cada vez
menos divorcios menos divorcio entre lo
dicho y lo hecho la contradicción entre
lo que decimos y hacemos que esa
diferencia entre lo que hacemos y
decimos cada vez sea menor cada vez a
menor quizás no podamos evitar las
contradicciones pero que esas
contradicciones sean los menores lo
menor posible porque si hay mucha
contradicción no solamente genera
perjuicio a la sociedad sino también es
porque estamos total y absolutamente
fragmentado y divididos
en una parte estamos mintiendo
absolutamente para mejorar es importante
que esa separación entre lo que decimos
y hacemos se vas achicando para lograr
una mejor sociedad no puedo
dejar de mencionar en esto del derecho a
la ciudad amable una cuestión que
fundamental que supera las dos variables
del tiempo y el espacio nosotros todos
estamos acostumbrados los cálculos que
el tiempo y espacio
para la ciudad amable necesitamos una
actitud propositiva una actitud
propositiva es decir una energía
positiva que supere la variable tiempo y
espacio si yo no tengo una actitud
propositiva y solamente me quejo ni
siquiera tengo una actitud de reclamo
sino esa comodidad la zona de confort la
famosa zona de confort de la queja
consuetudinaria
no superó estas variables y no logró
construir el derecho a la ciudad amable
pero si tengo una actitud propositiva de
participación de reclamo y dejo la queja
logró una cuestión que es fundamental
darle sentido y valor a las dos
variables de mi existencia
cuáles son tiempo y espacio
tenemos que recordar una cuestión de un
gran jurista argentino que terminó
exiliado en parís que es el padre de la
constitución argentina y que tiene que
ver con todo esto que enseñó mucho que
es el doctor juan bautista alberdi que
de verdad era doctor porque hizo el
doctorado
alberdi decía que nosotros los
argentinos somos buenos para somos
buenos para copiar lo malo y malo para
copiar lo bueno es decir que somos o
éramos doblemente malo
qué interesante sería lograr romper ese
desafío de juan bautista alberdi y decir
que somos
malos para copiar lo malo y muy buenos
para copiar lo bueno para lograr ser
doblemente bueno
por último quiero que reflexionemos que
estos desafíos del derecho a la ciudad
amable se logran fundamentalmente con
participación para la transformación de
nuestra ciudad con compromiso y
generosidad les pido que entre todos
podamos y a futuro y presente que entre
todos logremos construir este derecho
que es a la ciudad amable muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]